eh what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
these are my first thoughts and first
impressions on the Samsung Galaxy Note 3
before I even have any sort of hands-on
time where I've even ever even touched
the device now I don't usually do this
type of thing but so many of you guys
were asking for me to do some sort of
thoughts video on the note 3 that I
figured I would do it especially since I
was kind of hyping it up a lot in my
most recent videos and I talked about it
a lot on Twitter and on Facebook and
essentially you guys wanted to know what
I thought after the announcement so
there now you guys know you have an
input in the video selection process so
these are my first impressions of the
note 3 so overall I like what I see
obviously on paper this thing is an
absolute beast of a phone just like we
expect it it has a 5.8 inch 1080p
display has 3 gigabytes of RAM a 2.3
gigahertz quad-core processor which is
insane 32 or 64 gigabytes of storage and
a removable back and micro SD card slot
and a 13 megapixel camera and a 3200
million of our battery that's just a
little bit bigger than the old one and
of course they always managed to fit all
of this in a slightly thinner and
slightly lighter body than the previous
note sort of like we predicted and sort
of like they did with the Galaxy s4 so
this is a high-end phone with a high-end
price and high-end specs and a high-end
design and all of it so far looks about
right it's a high-end Galaxy Note 3 but
there were some unexpected things one is
that the note threes camera will be able
to take 4k video that's something that
the galaxy s4 can't do and something
that really almost no other phone can do
now of course I explained exactly what
4k video is in a separate explained
video so you can check that out right
below the like button on this video if
you want to watch that but essentially
this is much more than 1920 by 1080
video this video will be 3840 by 2160
and at a pretty solid bitrate too now I
was able to dig up a sample of it so 4k
video uploaded directly from a test unit
of the galaxy note 3 to YouTube and I'll
have a link to that below if you want to
watch it too directly but essentially
what we're seeing here is that it takes
really sharp video in 4k one all the way
zoomed out and you can see it on YouTube
you've probably able to see it in a raw
download of the file I won't be able to
judge the colors quite yet because I
wasn't there when they took the video
but what I do notice is when they zoom
in it maintains a lot of that detail
and you could easily use the zoomed in
footage as a 1080p video the unfortunate
thing is the Galaxy Note 3 camera does
not have optical image stabilization and
that would have helped a lot with the
shakiness and it's said because I really
would have liked have been able to use
that zoomed in 4k video as a 1080p video
by itself to share with people but it's
too shaky and it would really have been
really nice if it had optical image
stabilization to smooth that out a lot
now another thing that people don't seem
to be talking about all that much with
the Galaxy Note 3 and understandably so
because it's minor but it's the USB 3.0
it has a new port on the bottom of the
phone it'll still work with all your
backwards compatible USB cords that you
already have lying around but if you
pick up one of the new extremely ugly
USB 3.0 cables you'll be able to charge
your device much faster with a new
charger and transfer data between your
computer much faster if you plug it in
and move photos back and forth that way
so it's a new cable it's a much faster
way to charge and overall I'm actually
looking forward to that because this is
the phone with a big battery that tends
to take a while to charge so I'd like to
see a quick way to charge it up now
another thing is Samsung decided not to
go with the cheap feeling plastic on the
back of the note 3 that would feel a
little bit too cheap but instead they
went with a sort of a fake faux leather
with stitching on the back I'm not sure
exactly if that makes it feel more
premium or if that still feels really
cheap this is one of those totally
subjective things that people are either
gonna love or hate I'm gonna have to
wait until I get my hands on it it comes
in a black a white or a pink look I'm
probably gonna pick up the black one and
ideally it will feel better than the
glossy plastic on the back of the galaxy
s4 but I'm just gonna have to wait till
I get my hands on it because I have no
idea how a phone with a leatherette back
is going to feel in my hand and of
course since this is the Galaxy Note 3
they made a lot of improvements to their
TouchWiz UI on top of Android 4.3 to
make it more useful for people who like
to use the stylus so they added a lot of
new features a lot more of them with a
stylus and of course they like to name
all these things so of course you have
action memos pen windows s finder
scrapbook I'm probably not going to use
any of these I ended up not using a lot
of the the stylus features with the
Galaxy Note 2 I did a galaxy note 2
revisited video
like six months after I was first using
it and it turned out I really stopped
using it as a stylist phone I just used
it as a regular big phone so I'm feeling
like it's gonna be the same way with the
note 3 but either way that's the way I
see it here with the galaxy note 3 again
I can't wait to get my hands on the
device the whole point is I haven't seen
the device yet I haven't held it yet I
don't know how the camera performs I
don't know how long the battery lasts I
don't know how well the device itself
performs as it as fast as the s4 is even
of course it's a Snapdragon 800 and it's
an incredible phone on paper but I can't
wait to get my hands on it and get you
guys the full review and all my
impressions like literally as soon as I
can
so stay stay tuned for that be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already to see
videos like that and more tech coverage
ahead for the next couple months of tech
this has been mkbhd
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video thanks
[Music]